I
ok
striker yeah
this show is true communication to our
speakers in fact that we're not eating
food and getting
should I come sit down until you're
ready to go whatever you want over here
for now
this is being tweeted well so we we now
extreme our conferences and we have
people ask a question that's
survivability that's really cool so
students anyone our distance suit or
really anyone in the world then the
first one we did we had left 50 people
in this paper up there was a former
student of ours from Saudi Arabia who
happen to be in South Korea tweet a
question
hoping it'd be able to see the upcoming
slide on the machine but it doesn't look
like that oh I think it's just a mirror
I don't know yeah we'll see if I do well
welcome everyone I want to welcome you
all to our weekly research conference
which is at a slightly different time
this weekend this week because we have a
guest from out of town who most of you
know is an applicant for our faculty
position so Nicole Weisskopf is going to
talk to us today on her research
interest which is of interest to a
number of us as well on the use of
clinical data for clinical research so
Nicole is currently a PhD student in the
biomedical informatics program at
Columbia she's an NLM fellow so some of
you in the room are NLM fellows and and
may actually remember her talk from last
year's NLM trainees meeting that won an
award for the best talk prior to
Columbia she received a BA in psychology
from Wesleyan University and then spent
several years conducting eating disorder
research and schizophrenia research
before transitioning into informatics
she's currently a PhD candidate she's
going to tell us a little bit about the
research she's pursuing in her
dissertation that focuses on methods to
improve the efficiency and quality of
clinical research her dissertation
research addresses the problem of data
quality as it relates to the reuse of
electronic health record data in ops
relational research as we do now with
all of our conferences we are streaming
this live so there may be any number of
people out there in the world who are
listening to this and should you have
any comments or questions you should
tweet them to our Twitter tag at ohsu
informatics if we ask that you put the
hashtag d mice comp C DMI CEC nof but
will actually monitor the whole stream
and so if people want to ask questions
that way we can and then like all talks
we will post this to our website so I'm
going to turn it over to Nicole good
afternoon everyone can everyone hear me
okay great well thank you for having me
here so today I'm going to be discussing
some of the research that I've been
doing as part of my dissertation on
enabling the reuse of electronic health
record data through data quality
assessment so to start with I wanted to
give a little bit of background about
myself and how I ended up in informatics
so my original plan was to pursue a
degree in research psychology so my
first position out of undergrad was at a
center called cam a top of Toronto I was
with a concurrent eating disorder in
addiction clinic and I was very excited
when I got there because their plan was
to digitize all of their past diagnostic
and clinical assessments and then we are
going to do retrospective research on
this newly digitized data and what my
position ended up being was basically
taking about 10 of these filing cabinets
full of clinical diagnostics and trying
to dump them into their brand-new ms
access database and I start doing this
and I quickly realized a couple of
problems one thing was the Access
database was set up for example to want
a specific age of onset for certain
diagnosis their symptoms and instead
because the the actual assessments were
for clinical purposes they would say
something like on set was during grade
school it was very young when I would
end up going down the hall and
cracking down the original clinician and
trying to nail them down on the specific
age there are also problems with data
entry where they would only want a
certain kind of diagnosis like there was
only space to input one personality
disorder if you're familiar with this
clinical population they usually have
multiple personality disorders so what I
ended up doing instead was building an
entirely new ms access database from
scratch that addressed at least some of
these problems and we ended up being
able to do a little bit of research at
the very end but mostly that was my
entire time there and after that I moved
on to schizophrenia research where I
spent two years and when I got there
they had just implemented a much more
robust database and they would take all
these different demographics all these
different assessments electrophysiology
behavioral tasks and put them into this
database and my job was to kind of
maintain that and then to extract data
sets for research after the fact it was
a really cool project and I ended up
getting more and more interested in the
actual research issues instead of the
psychology issues so what could they do
to improve their workflow what could be
automated what were some of the problems
with the system and the fact that the
database wasn't released set up to grow
as the research itself expanded so long
the way I realized that I really wanted
to do was informatics and I ended up
going to Columbia University largely
because I wanted to with dr. Chung hua
wang who was specializing in clinical
research informatics I was also
fortunate enough to end up working with
doctors bakken cryptic and Wilcox and
originally I was going to look at
electronic data capture systems and
Tamar really encouraged me to look at
the reuse of EHR data and just as
transition from paper records to
electronic records the current
technology and existing models of
success have put us in a better position
today than we have been in before to
realize the promises of health
information technology to advance
research this is from a whiner an MBA
editorial and I think that it's pretty
obvious why there are advantages to
being able to reuse existing clinical
data decreased costs increased
efficiency and the
at every stage in the research process
at the recruitment point the retention
point and also the data collection point
there's also the fact that we often have
an incredibly large volume of data when
we're talking about clinical data at
Columbia we have approximately four
million unique patient records just
pretty significant comparing that to a
randomized controlled trial and there's
also the fact that we have a
representative patient population one of
the criticisms of traditional research
is that you have these very strict
eligibility criteria and a lot of the
times the patients that you're
recruiting are not representative of the
patients that you're actually going to
be treating when you're using clinical
data you know that you have actual
patients there in actual care settings
that is potentially a major advantage
especially if you're talking about
something like patient-centered outcomes
research or comparative effectiveness
research this inevitably led to the next
question though our electronic health
record data of sufficient quality to be
used in clinical research so there's all
this promise but we know that there are
problems with the data and if you talk
to people who are clinical trial asst
they'll talk about an error rate of
maybe like two out of every thousand
pieces of data are incorrect or have
some kind of problem if you talk to
clinicians you don't know exactly what
that error rate is but you know that
it's a lot higher
so to begin tackling this problem I
first looked at how people were already
approaching HR data quality I started
looking at the literature and I quickly
discovered a couple of problems first
everybody talks about it differently
there's no accepted terminology there's
no standard model and this is
interesting because in other fields
there are very well accepted models this
is the Wang and strong model outside of
informatics almost everybody at least
talks about this even if they're not
actually using it it's very well
validated and it doesn't get used in
informatics recently people are starting
to talk about it but at the time not
really everybody measures data quality
differently most approaches to this are
completely at hawk there's no systematic
approach so everybody's doing something
different and therefore unsurprisingly
everybody actually gets different
results in their data quality finding
these are pulled from to literature
reviews on HR data quality the top one
is the Hogan and Wagner review that a
lot of people reference so you see a
huge range of correctness between 44 and
a hundred percent each range and
completeness and very interestingly the
chana daal paper looked at different
clinical variables different phenomena
so specifically for blood pressure
there's a completeness ranging from just
about 0% to over fifty percent that's
one type of clinical variable so what I
realized pretty quickly was if we want
to be able to assess data quality if we
want to know if the data are good enough
to be used we need to develop systematic
approaches
so this is my roadmap to eh our data
quality assessment and my first step was
to perform a more in-depth literature
review so what I want to find out is
what is the state of the field how are
in fermentation is talking about
measuring electronic health record data
quality and this if anyone's interested
has been published in J Mia so part of
the problem with doing this kind of
research there are no mesh terms in
PubMed for data quality so we used a
whole bunch of different different
search strings went through the original
batch of results and then ended up doing
an ancestor search to try and catch all
the stuff that we'd originally missed we
ended up with a final poll a pool of 95
relevant articles we wanted these to be
original research we wanted them to be
peer-reviewed and they we wanted them to
be talking about actual methods of data
quality assessment and from each of
these articles we pulled the dimensions
of data quality that we're being studied
the methods that were being used and
then we kind of align those two things
with one another and we went through
them iteratively to try and identify
some basic categories so here you can
see all of the different terms we used
that discuss that were intended to
describe data quality and we group them
into these five dimensions of
completeness concordance correctness
currency implausibility I'm going to go
through this in a bit more detail so
completeness is the most commonly
assessed dimension of data quality in
the literature and it's basically asking
is the truth about a patient present in
the EHR one point that I want to make is
when you're talking about completeness
often clinicians will describe this as
was something that was observed recorded
when you talk to researchers they're
just asking is this thing that I want in
the data can I get this they don't care
who is observed in the first place
because that's not what's interesting to
them they just want to know if they have
it and if they can use it correctness is
an element that is present in the EHR
true currency is an element in the EHR a
relevant representation of the patient
state at a given point in time because a
lot of clinical phenomena will change
over time concordance is their agreement
between or within elements in the
char or between are within elements in
the EHR and another data source so if
you have potentially the same variable
two different times are they an
agreement with each other if you have
two different variables maybe you have a
lab test in the diagnosis a diagnosis do
those agree with one another and lastly
plausibility does an element in the EHR
makes sense in light of other knowledge
about what that element is measuring so
this is kind of a bit of a face validity
dimension I also extracted seven
approaches to data quality assessment
the most common was the use of a gold
standard or reference standard which is
when you take another data source or you
combine data sources to create your
reference standard and you use it as
your source of truth one problem with
this is often you don't have a gold
standard available so the fact that this
is the most common method is really
pretty problematic also what people call
a gold standard often is not actually a
gold standard next is data element
agreement so this is used a lot to
measure that dimension of concordance
are two things in the in the database in
agreement with each other element
presents usually used for completeness
is this thing I want actually available
data source agreement might be when you
look to see if your EHR data agree with
something in a registry or paper
documents that are kept concurrently but
there's no assumption that one is more
accurate than the other you're just
trying to compare them distribution
comparison is when you take a
distribution or summary of aggregated
data and you compare it to what you
might see as an expected distribution so
you have your patients then you have
registry data for totally different
patients and you just look at those
distributions and you see if they align
with one another if they don't you have
a good reason for it or not validity
check very simple might be something
like you have a range limit on blood
pressure or heart rate if your data
value exceeds or is below that you may
have a data quality problem and lastly
log review which is usually used for
currency and it's when we look to see if
the information the metadata attached to
the day
interest can tell us anything about the
quality of the data so this takes those
95 original articles and it maps each of
those dimensions of data quality for
most common to least common to the
methods of assessment for most common to
least common and again you see gold
standard up at the top that's very
common for completeness and correctness
you've got somewhere you have almost a
one-to-one relationship currency and log
review that's essentially the only time
you'll see those two things so what we
really got out of this at the end is
still this idea that data quality
assessment is ad hoc it's not systematic
it's overly reliant on things like gold
standards and these were problems we
were going to have to address going
forward so this was our first step in a
roadmap to the data call the assessment
and from that we got the the set of
dimensions of data quality these methods
of assessment and the fact that we need
is this pneumatic approach
so for the next step we wanted to come
back to the fact that actual data
quality findings are so incredibly
variable we know part of that is because
of differences in which variables were
interested in though again I want to
point out that channa daal result where
for blood pressure there's still so much
variability could be partially
institutional it could depend on the
culture of clinical care that you're
looking at but our suspicion was the
fact the fact that we have this
variability and what methods are being
used and how we are operationalizing
data quality concepts is itself causing
a lot of the variability and findings
and this brings us to a common
definition of quality so Duran
originally proposed this idea of fitness
for youth quality is fitness for use and
that's not just data quality but any
kind of quality and Redman took it a
step further specifically for data
quality and said data are of high
quality if they are fit for their
intended uses and operations
decision-making and planning data are
fit for use if they are free of defects
and possess desired features so what
this would suggest is that depending
upon what your study is what you want
out of that data you're going to have a
different idea of data quality and
that's going to give you different
findings even for the same data set so
in our second study we wanted to answer
this question is data quality cast
dependent how do you date how do you
definitions and operationalization of
data quality affect data quality
findings this was published in j bi so i
mentioned this briefly but i wanted to
talk about how we are defining
completeness again so data can disappear
or go missing because they are either
observed or unobserved originally and
then those observed data are either
recorded or unrecorded so you've got two
points where the incompleteness can take
place and again I want to point out we
can to stick to the the clinician based
description of completeness that is
anything that's observed should be
recorded it could be you want data that
weren't observed in the first place
so this is a very simple way of
conceptualizing the patient record in
the EHR we have a whole bunch of data
types it's a longitudinal patient record
so everything is recorded at these
different points in time and we have
this for every single patient so using
that basic conceptualization of a
patient record I just want to give more
possible definitions of completeness so
here's the clinician definition
documentation completeness where all of
these observations are inside that
record they're all inside that box so
everything that was observed was
reported this is very hard to measure
without a gold standard so we had to
find some tricks to get around that
another possible way of defining
completeness is that you have a breadth
of data a record is complete when it
contains all the desired or expected
types of data orthogonal to that density
completeness a record is complete when
it contains a specified frequency of
data points over time and lastly
predictive completeness a record is
complete when it contains sufficient
information to predict the clinical
phenomenon of interest so here we don't
have any specific data requirements
there's nothing explicit but we want to
be able to predict that red point off in
the future you can have two very
different records that both let you
predict what you're interested in
they're both complete according to this
definition this is something that might
be more relevant for someone who's doing
data mining or predictive modeling so
for this we used all of the data in the
Columbia University clinical data
warehouse it's a at this time was
approximately 3.9 million unique patient
records we didn't use every type of data
for each patient we kind of
operationalize each of these definitions
using certain data types just to
demonstrate an idea this is our general
population and this is the overall
finding so these are the four different
definitions of completeness overlaid and
again this is going to change depending
upon which variables you're looking at
you weren't looking at all of them but
the fact remains that there's some
overlap for some definitions but there's
a lot of places where you're not getting
full overlap i also want to touch on one
thing quickly which is you can see this
the second circle the nested circle
which is patients who have at least one
clinical data point is um i guess about
fifty five percent which is interesting
in and of itself that is because we have
a lot of patients who are in our master
patient index but they were seeing
people who didn't have electronic health
records where they had records that were
not dumping directly into the clinical
data warehouse which is a huge
governance problem all on its own in the
salsa the fact that this is historic
data if we're just limiting it to like
the last two years it would probably be
much larger shapes what I really want to
emphasize is if you want the overlap of
all four of these definitions if you
have fewer than one percent of our
patients so we've really found is
depending upon how you're defining what
seems like a fairly simple data quality
concept what your specific research up
needs are you're going to get very
different results so this point you've
shown the data quality depends on your
research task and also that we're going
to need a dynamic data quality
assessment approach you don't have a
one-size-fits-all solution for all
research so anytime someone wants to
conduct a study if they want to decide
if the research are going to have
quality the DQ a methods are going to
have to respond to their specific needs
so we did at this point we had like kind
of a little offshoot of this study that
I want to go through very quickly but we
thought it was very interesting we
wanted to know who are these point six
percent who actually have a lot of data
according to all four definitions in our
hypothesis is that sick patients have
more data I think this is what most
people would assume what's important
about that is it means that if you are
selecting based on the availability of
data you are selecting sicker patients
so you're automatically creating bias in
your study and we wanted to see if this
is true or not because it's something
people assume but it is kind of not
really discussed that much
this was published in the AMIA
proceedings of last year and we also
have a more complicated version of the
same analysis that looks at work hope
areas that under review right now we're
hoping for good reviews so we needed was
a health status indicator and I was
working with a nano physiologist on this
project so we use the the a-si physical
status scores which range from one to
six one being healthy six being brain
dead we limited it to groups 1 through 4
this is a big limitation in this study
it's a very specific type of sample but
it's one of the only physical status
indicators that's not dependent upon the
completeness of the data so something
like the charlson comorbidity index see
you can't actually calculate it for most
of your patients because you don't have
all the information you need for
completeness we did simple counts of
days with medication actions so orders
or stop giving this medication and
counts of days with laboratory results
we have 5,000 patients and we only
wanted people who had one anesthesia one
episode of anesthesia and nothing in the
past year and we looked at the counts of
data in the preceding year we used a
kruskal-wallis one-way analysis of
variance which is a nonparametric test
and this is the original distribution of
patients across these a sa bins you can
see why we use to nonparametric tests
they're very uneven sample sizes and we
found what we expected so over here
you've got the amount of data across a
sa scores for medication orders and for
laboratory results and there's a
significant difference between all of
these except groups one to two so as we
expected sick patients do have more data
and here just so that you can see why
this really might matter if you're doing
a study this is again the distribution
of patients over a sa scores if you have
no threshold for how much data you need
this is a few need 10 points and you can
see this distribution is very much
skewed in a different direction that
second population is going to be a lot
sicker than the first one
this is interesting because you can see
that data quality is actually going to
covary with patient health in some
circumstances which is problematic so
going back to that roadmap to data
quality assessment our next step was
that we wanted to actually talk to the
consumers of these data so we wanted to
understand the perceptions and needs of
clinical researchers who might be
interested in reusing these data and
this is work that the data analysis is
all done we're working on a manuscript
right now
so eat a couple of questions going into
this what our research or perceptions of
EHR data quality are these perceptions a
barrier to reuse and lastly how do
researchers currently handle data
quality problems because we are
interested in perceptions and how those
perceptions might change behaviors we
use the proceed proceed model to inform
this research this is usually used for
modeling health behaviors but it can be
extended nicely for this kind of
situation and we were focusing
specifically on this section right here
predisposing factors enabling factors
and reinforcing factors so predisposing
factor is something that makes you more
or less inclined to engage in a behavior
an enabling factor is something that
makes it easier or harder to engage in
that behavior and a reinforcing factor
it's something that rewards or punishes
you for engaging in that behavior and
here the final outcome the final
behavior of interest would be the
increased efficiency of clinical
research in the intermediary one is
reuse of EHR data
so we developed an interview guide we
didn't want to just straight up ask you
know what are your reinforcing factors
what are your enabling factors so
instead we asked clinical researchers
about their actual experiences using EHR
data their attitudes towards those data
and their intentions to use those data
in the future and I know there's kind of
a wall of text here and I don't want to
spend too long on it I interviewed ten
clinical researchers we use purposive
sampling because we specifically wanted
to identify people who would be targets
of this kind of data quality assessment
intervention there were all researchers
within the cumc community we used a
combined inductive and deductive
approach so the inductive approach would
be the fact that we applied this phase
three of the proceed pro Cee'd model we
had a theoretical basis going in but
within those major categories of
different kinds of factors we derive
themes and that aspect was deductive so
I'm actually going to start from the
bottom I'm going to start with the
reinforcing factors and work my way up
because it goes from the simplest to the
most complicated so as you would expect
the reinforcing factors to reusing EHR
data or its facilitation of research so
the EHR data facilitates a tremendous
amount of research that wouldn't be
possible otherwise without exhaustive
review or manual processing and
facilitation of publication the new
york-presbyterian database could be a
paper generating monster
a good monster so the enabling factors
things like availability and
accessibility of data the fact that it
can be very difficult to identify
relevant data or relevant cohorts and
lastly the skills to actually reuse
those data and a lot of these clinical
researchers would get these big dumps of
data and they had no idea what to do
with them I'm not going to go through
all of these but I just thought I know
anyone who's used a discovery process
with getting these data will identify
with this that's a big barrier here I
mean you can wait a long time to get
results because there's really just two
people writing programs to pull stuff
out not actually the case I know it
seems like that to people who want the
data I had someone talking about
throwing a request over a wall and you
never know what's going to come back out
and then the predisposing factors were
we're really the meat of the results
were and this was the interesting part
and they fell into a number of
categories for existing knowledge of
data quality problems beliefs about the
factors that are impacting the data
quality with an EHR beliefs about the
EHR data quality beliefs about other
people's attitudes towards the HR data
because some of the researchers said
well you know I know this is true but i
think these other clinicians these other
researchers don't have the same
awareness ideal beliefs about
requirements for reuse what you should
be doing if you're using the data and
lastly their general their overall
attitudes towards reuse so in terms of
knowledge of the acute problems data
quality problems we got another set of
data quality dimensions to go along with
those literature review results some of
them are the same so completeness
correctness fragmentation is the fact
that often they would want some data
that was in two or more different places
within the EHR concordance again they
saw non structured data as being a data
quality problem when it came to reuse so
anything that was in a free text field
or free entry field granularity often
you might have a diagnosis that you're
interested in but it's not going to have
enough information so maybe you're
interested in pancreatic cancer and you
can find that diagnosis but you want to
know where in the pancreas
that cancer actually is and that's not
as likely to be the present and lastly
signal-to-noise there's a tremendous
amount of data most of it's irrelevant
so how do you find the parts that are
relevant and pull them out and how do
you know what's safe to discard in terms
of beliefs about factors impacting data
quality there are some thoughts on the
traits of the data themselves so
sometimes manual versus automatically
recorded data or optional versus
required data system features whether a
big one a lot of people felt that the
EHR itself was responsible for the
generation of poor quality data and
lastly user behaviors so it's a
clinician in a big rush or they just
clicking on that first option that
default value so they can get on with
what they're trying to do one common
example is nobody wants to use the
indication for a radiology exam because
everyone just goes into the pulldown
clicks the first thing shoots off the
request you never ever use that data in
terms of beliefs about EHR data quality
it's legendary among try lists that
what's in a chart the kind of rules
about what you put in there who puts it
in and how careful they are and what not
is pretty sloppy so they were saying
this in contrast to a clinical trial
where you have this huge book that tells
you exactly how you're collecting
everything what you're collecting you're
probably doing double entry for at least
some of it so I'm pretty negative views
on EHR data quality or negative beliefs
in terms of beliefs about requirements
for you reuse I thought this was very
interesting because this can inform data
quality assessment approaches so a lot
of people thought that there should be a
space for the clinician to actually be
involved in the assessment process or at
least the interpretation of the results
as clinicians I think when you deal with
all these types of situations you
understand the process by which this
data is generated I think that's why
it's important to have clinician
involvement in this kind of research so
basically what they're saying is they
don't want a black box process they
don't want a program where you toss them
data you get some number because they
don't trust it they want to actually
look at the data and say well I have
this clinical knowledge I have this
knowledge of the system I know that I've
recorded this these are my concerns so
they want there to be a certain kind of
subjectivity involved in the data
quality assessment process and lastly
the attitudes towards reuse I'm not a
huge fan yet but I'm a believer I think
there are a lot of opportunities there
and I saw a lot of that it's conflicted
and then the second one I think those
very important it's not even a question
of positive or negative because i think
it's the way of the future or the way of
the present so regardless of the
problems with the data even if we find
overwhelming data quality issues people
are going to use these data because the
the opportunities that they have are
really tremendous so it's not just
something where we can say don't do this
we don't think it's a good idea we need
to find the best ways to enable this for
use so from this step what we found was
another set of dimensions of data
quality the fact that reuse is going to
occur despite any concerns about data
quality that might exist and the fact
that there is some kind of clinician
involvement desired in the data quality
assessment process so the next step
which is what I'm currently working on
is the development of data quality
assessment guidelines bringing in all of
the knowledge that we learn use previous
studies
this is a quick recap what do we know at
this point we know that EHR data will
occur regardless of data quality
problems we know that we need systematic
evidence based data quality assessment
approaches instead of the ad-hoc
approaches that have been largely used
in informatics so far we know that we
need a flexible and dynamic approach to
data quality assessment to handle the
different data quality needs this
concept of fitness for use and we know
that it would be ideal at least from the
researcher perspective to have some kind
of clinician involvement and data
quality assessment so the last step
which is currently underway is the
development of these data quality
assessment guidelines and just about
done with the first draft of these the
next step is going to be evaluation and
then further iteration on the
development so from the dimensions of
data quality identified in the
literature review and the interviews
with clinical researchers we identified
these three core kind of atomic
dimensions of data quality data that are
good quality are complete correct and
current and I just wanted to remind you
of this simple conceptualization of
patient data in the electronic health
record you can kind of see that there
are three dimensions of the data we've
got patients variables and time and what
we did was we created this three by
three framework and to kind of go along
with this idea fitness for use of
dynamic data quality assessment we know
that different studies are going to have
different requirements are going to have
different data some of them will be
longitudinal some of them won't be they
may have different numbers of variables
you may have something where someone is
just doing a very simple case review
versus having a large number of patients
so depending upon those studies you're
going to have different and different
kinds of data that are involved you're
going to have different kinds of
assessment methods that you can actually
employ for each of those dimensions of
data quality and these methods which
fill in the nine cells inside are
largely pulled from that original
literature review and then pulled from
some other
you're on data quality from outside the
informatics world there's a lot here I
don't want you guys to read all of it
but I'm going to end up taking you
through one specific example for now I
want to show you where this framework
fits in in the overall data quality
assessment guidelines it's in order to
determine which of these assessment
methods are actually relevant the first
step is that there are a series of
questions to identify the scope of your
study so it's going to be questions
about your data needs and your data
quality needs after you answer all of
those questions you're going to have
some subset of these nine items that are
going to be relevant for your study
relevant data quality assessment actions
and those in turn back to assessment and
reporting recommendation so these are
examples of some of the questions to
identify scope so depending upon how you
answered earlier questions and I believe
there are 13 or 14 questions total and
you don't answer all events so it's a
pretty quick process it should take only
about five or ten minutes so questions
like do you have a specific time frame
or frames of interest for example do you
have a range of dates or a specific
season that you're interested in and
then you have an answer sheet where you
can mark down what your responses do you
require expect that different variables
should be recorded and certain order
relative to one another depending upon
what your answers are to all these
questions you're going to have different
kinds of assessment methods that you're
going to want to do so this is the one
specific example I'm going to take you
through so say you answer all these
questions and it says you should do you
know subset whatever of these nine items
and one of them is 1 B 1 B is the
intersection of correctness across
variables or I'm sorry correctness
across patients so the distribution of
very values is plausible across patient
and this is kind of derived from one of
the methods that identified in the
literature review and again one of the
things that I wanted to do is stay away
from gold standard reliance so you're
not going to see any methods here that
say you
your source of truth see how many of
your items are correct so we're kind of
getting the closest proxy to accuracy
that we can so this is one approach you
know you've multiple patients you want
to assess correct this is this
distribution of values plausible across
patients and you can do this for certain
types of variables this is what the
recommendation would actually look like
and there are actually two different
approaches for the specific one I'm
giving the second and part of the goal
here was to make it very readable to
make it something that was easy to look
at easy to parse and interpret and each
of these recommendations includes the
measure that you can actually do so the
method what you would report and then it
gives a very brief example just if it's
difficult to conceptualize what it's
suggesting so for this one the mother
the measure actually talks about
identifying an external source of data
on the same concept you're interested in
and taking that distribution and you
compare it either statistically or
visually to the distribution of that
variable within your own data set you
report whether there is alignment or
misalignment between those data sources
how those distributions would actually
differ and whether there are possible
confounders so confounder in this
situation might be well I know the
population for that registry is very
different from mine if you don't have
some kind of confounder like that you
might have to assume that there might be
statistical systematic bias for example
this is a simple example just so people
can actually see what it means to take
two distributions and compare them
against one another and then there are
references so if someone wants to delve
a little more deeper into this idea they
can pull up these pre-existing papers or
books that use this approach and they
can see it operationalized them a little
bit more detail we're going to be using
an iterative design approach the first
round is going to involve sending this
out to a set of experts what we're doing
right now is actually working on
developing our criteria for who is an
expert we've developed a fairly
extensive evaluation instrument that is
looking at validity comprehensiveness
clarity and ease of use and then we're
going to do a rounded redesign so what's
next after that evaluation after that
iterative design so I'm involved in two
projects that are looking at data
quality assessment I'm working with a
really great group of people led
primarily by michael kahn out of
Colorado so for the EDM forum we have a
smaller project which is working on the
development of a comprehensive framework
for data quality assessment and
comparative effectiveness research and
this is going to involve interfacing
with a lot of different experts not just
in informatics or healthcare but data
quality more broadly coming to an
agreed-upon framework seeking feedback
on that and the publication of a series
of white papers so the hope is to really
kind of get that out there into the CER
communicate community get everyone on
the same page and then for the Corey
grant we are working on building
patient-centered outcomes research value
and integrity with data quality and
transparency standards so this EDM
project kind of falls nicely into that
Corey grant or it's going to be the
first step is developing this unified
framework of data quality assessment but
then it's going to take it several steps
further into actually operationalizing
that model developing software packages
that can be applied to data sets
actually testing it out on a number of
data sets including a lot and then also
taking it a step further in developing
real reporting standards so things that
could go into a photo quote table 1 in
any paper that is published using a HR
data and then more personally something
that I'm interested in you may have
noticed that when i talk about EHR data
i talk about everything after the whole
data life cycle so you come over here
you pull the data out you've got your
data set what do you do with it then so
that point there's not as much room to
actually improve data quality the data
are what they are and they're certain
techniques you can use but it's if the
static data set at that point but EHR
data is actually kind of a living
creature and it's collected it early in
this data quality this data life cycle
so you may have points where the patient
eats with the clinician you have times
when laboratory and medication data are
getting dumped in you have points where
administrative services are going
through those data and generating new
data you potentially have points where
patients are interfacing with their data
directly either through PHR or possibly
in certain certain medical offices you
actually are given access to your data
on a tablet so there's the possibility
for change in generation there and what
I'm interested in is finding those
points in the data life cycle where we
can actually improve data quality or
check data quality and the trick is
going to be finding times where the
interests of those different
stakeholders the clinicians the patients
the administrators are in alignment with
the desire to improve data quality
because you don't want to just keep
adding more verda and you don't want to
say document more carefully we're
certainly not going to do double data
entry so perhaps medication
reconciliation would be an opportunity
for that where there is an interest from
the clinician and the patient and really
getting good data there what can we do
to help enable that process so that's
what I'm beginning to look at right now
and I wanted to thank all my committee
members and my funders and if you have
any questions I would be happy to take
them
hold down just like one example the I
think the icd-9 has like zero references
to periodontal and the icd-10 has a
bunch of them so now it's possible to be
able to track babies born with mothers
who have that condition and so at one
month did you see this six months when
you're too but they have to record it
first so is just for one example is
there some awareness then I see ten now
there's a whole bunch more stuff that
can be noted and tracked and how can you
get that to be recorded you mean how can
you get people to switch over to using
icd-10 codes or well yeah now thurs that
there's that much more things that can
be quantified is there now a greater
awareness that that can be done and it
should be done etcetera no I mean
there's a lot of there are a lot of
places where the whole issue of
standards and vocabularies is going to
interface with native quality virtually
because everyone's using different
standards I think even if people know
that there are data that they can record
this issue completeness is difficult
because people aren't going to record
things that aren't relevant to the
specific clinical issue that you are
interested in so yes it's great if there
are more things that we can quantify
does that mean that they are going to be
quantified I don't know is that
answering your question
is the point that you can look at more
things now to potentially yeah yeah I
mean the amount of things that we have
data on it's just going to continue to
expand and we are going to have more and
more different kinds of sources of data
there may be more automated data that's
recording things with greater frequency
there's just going to be more of this
hopefully weather that actually means
any improvements in data quality or just
more data with quality problems that's
hard to say yeah great great talk and
area of interest to a lot of us as I was
listening I was thinking about there's
sort of another wrinkle to this and I'd
be curious in your thoughts and how it
fits into your model you alluded to it a
couple point a couple points but one
thing that will be seeing as time goes
on is transforming of data you know the
sort of prototype example being like NLP
processing of a text note but other and
there may be other ways you know for
example genomics data as it kind of
comes down the pike and we learn new
things about genomic variants that you
know may or may not be represented in
the chart so how do you I guess does
your model account for the fact that
data may isn't necessarily just static
it you know it's being transformed along
the way either when it's generated or
down the road how does your model
account for that I think that's that's
one of the pretty major limitations of
this that it is assuming that you've got
your data set and it is what it is I
think those the model and the the
applications that are going to be
developed as part of the quarry approach
are going to hopefully be more robust
and they will be able to deal with that
fact that the data are changing
some of the methods I think could be
applied to different kinds of data
different modalities of data instead of
just the strict clinical structured
information there's no reason you
couldn't extract information using NLP
and apply these same methods something
like genomic data would take a different
kind of knowledge base that I'm not
nearly as familiar with so I'm sure
there are kind of parallel methods that
you could be using so you mostly talked
about this in terms of clinical research
but there's seems like there's a lot of
similar issues in terms of using this
data for clinical quality measures which
aren't typically considered secondary
use but are from a point of certain
point of view so how do you think your
work applies in that domain I think
there's probably a lot of overlap the
caveat with that is I did try to really
target this to researcher needs so I
think would be interesting to sit down
with people who are involved with
quality metrics quality of care and talk
to them about what their needs are how
they're using the data what their
concerns are and see if maybe this
approach would align with what they're
trying to do I would hope that there's a
fair amount of overlap
so very interested in this from I think
related to Aaron's questions so we think
a lot about stakeholder incentives and
willingness to improve data as we're
trying to improve clinical quality
measures right and so we think about the
whole life cycle of the data when we do
that but we don't have a good way to
document our assessments especially
where they vary in terms of data quality
by the source and how far we've gotten
with this and I was sort of wondering if
you could reflect on you know you're
talking about researcher needs and as
you're pulling data and assessing its
quality and you're going to report it
which is a lovely thing to do but what
about and the source of the data the
sort of metadata about this data and its
quality could some of this be applied
there and if so how if not what would we
need to extend yeah a lot of people are
very interested in the idea of metadata
like you said some of the researchers
who I spoke to wanted to have that
attach to everything so it's not just
who's recording it where it's being
recorded those basic concepts but what
they wanted was if someone had sat down
and done chart review for a hundred
patients they wanted that to be noted
somewhere where they at least wanted
that final data set to have that
information attached to it so someone
didn't feel like they had to do that
work over again I mean it's there's
certainly the potential for the metadata
itself to be much more much larger than
the data that you are actually using I
think there's a potential for a little
bit of trouble if you are talking about
something like fitness for use where
someone might do an assessment and then
you attach that assessment result to the
data and someone wants to use it for
something else you don't know that
result is still going to hold but I do
think that there are certain kinds of
information that are still helpful so
one thing I mentioned very briefly was
the fact that the different traits the
data might be able to impact data
quality so was this required or optional
for input was it automatic or
annual recording so those types of
information might be proxies for data
quality so adding that in could give
helpful information Nicole I had a
questions probably similar to bills and
errands that one of the things it's a
little bit overwhelming about the HR
that there's so much data that's in it
and I think I guess it's a two-part
question one is that in part to you
talked about sort of data completeness
through this big clinical data
repository and so the question is what
kind of data was it looked like it was
kind of lab data and exam finding data
and I guess the second question is um in
terms of using these data for sort of
secondary purposes what do you see as
the most promising types of data is I
guess I'm thinking problem lists
diagnose these things like that and so
what's your thought about those so for
your first question the kinds of data we
used I didn't want to put up too much
text it was mostly medication orders
laboratory orders the presence or
absence of clinical documentation so a
note but not the actual data in the note
basic demographic information so we
tried to choose things were kind of
representative data types but yeah the
array of different things we could have
like that is close to unlimited in a lot
of ways so can you tell me your second
question once more let me ask a second
question so that wasn't my ratio second
question but with them the lab stuff
because I think that um what I'm
thinking of is in terms of if some if a
doctor typed something into the EHR or
just clicks the button did they click
the right button and do you think the
findings that you're seeing in terms of
the lab data and the medication orders
would generalize to you know did the
doctor click the right button or did
they put the right diagnosis or
categorize it correctly and because I
think that's the other aspect of no data
completeness so if the assumptions that
you might make about the reporting
practices if those data would hold true
for other kinds
I think it's going to really depend on
the system that you're using how
intelligent the EHR is how difficult it
makes to input the kind of data you're
interested in we again we use this
because they're kind of the most
commonly requested types of data but I
mean if you're getting into more
complicated data so maybe data that's
been abstracted out of radiology
something like that yeah those processes
that are behind it are very different so
I think the methods could probably be
extended but the findings the
expectations of the quality I don't know
about that so much think that there are
there are several people here who are
interested in things like you know
quality reporting and you know exactly
this type of stuff I think there'd be a
lot of potential for stuff that you know
what you're interested in I guess the
bottom line is don't don't let the what
is it the old saying that don't let
perfect be the enemy of good just a
quick one we had a PhD student who
graduated last year who was kind of
combining neuroscience with informatics
and one of the things he talked about a
lot was in the neuroscience world they
also have that terminology problem where
a lot of scientists use different terms
for the same thing same cell types of
that sort of thing and I was wondering
if you had encountered that because your
background is related to neuroscience
and and whether you thought their
solutions which were to kind of build
alliances or consortiums to agree on
terminology if you think that's going to
be something of a solution for what you
were talking about early in your talk
where you were talking about that
problem all right um
I wouldn't say that's something that I
personally ran into when I was doing the
neuroscience research we were kind of in
such like a very specific area that I
think everyone in that area was pretty
much using the same terminology i guess
if we gotten into the broader biological
issues and that may have been something
that I ran into more in terms of trying
to create consortiums and come to an
agreed-upon terminology that's really
what I'm trying to do working with
Michael Cohn and Meredith Nam and all
these other people who are on that
McCrory grant is the idea to hopefully
get this unified model of data quality
that is well accepted by the informatics
or clinical community and hopefully
disseminate it because that's the
problem people coming up with keep
coming up with standards and then
instead of accepting the standard
someone else comes up with a different
one so that's that's the goal here we'll
have to see how successfully how
successful we are with it
no tweets no one was really excited
about data quality I can't imagine
George on Twitter maybe I mean could be
wrong